fait non non les crues de la garonne ont
provoqué ces derniers jours de
nombreuses migrations ichtyologique
souvent fortes inattendue c'est ainsi
que des pêcheurs bretons ont ramené dans
leurs filets une livre d'ablettes et une
douzaine de grenouilles tandis que des
taquineurs de carpes parisien du canal
saint-martin remontait de leur ligne de
magnifiques poissons marins selon haroun
tazieff ce phénomène est extrêmement
banal mais il faut dire que notre grand
vulcanologue icaunais que dalle en
pisciculture
mais vous la mort c'est à quoi là
dans ce match
c'est quoi ça une quoi une gouge net
c'est gros comme ça et vous avez pris
quelque chose non oui
ça vous en bouche un coin se déplace pas
encore des conneries comme ça
ah ouais
un turbo
[Musique]
c'est un turbo
ses voisins c'est une truite
seul
une seule dans le canal saint-martin ça
va pas c'est un turbo
ça se voit ça se vend bien ça un turbo
j'ai pris la barre de fer là dessous
sous la cascade la barre ils n'avaient
d'abord ça se passe comme ça ou pas il
veut m'acheter des orages et l'achète il
veut me l'acheter 18 francs un turbo qui
vaut au moins 45 km celui fêté ses cinq
ans pourquoi vous êtes directeur du pont
avant-hier dupont la richesse du renvoi
la chef du projet chez le débat je vous
préviens moi c'est parce que s'il ya un
garde-pêche qui pensaient d'accord il
vous a bit more
notre cameraman réussi à saisir sur le
vif le douloureux étonnement de ce
pêcheur parisien au moment où il vient
de sortir du canal saint martin ce rouge
et grondin venu tout droit de l'océan
par la porte de la chapelle
[Musique]
non
quand la garonne sort de son lit je
rentre dans le mien dit un sage proverbe
néo zélandais certes mais encore faut-il
savoir ce que le banc guichard i
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fait étonnant non
[Musique]